[Musique]
oh
la dernière fois on a déjà parlé de la
déraisonnable efficacité du dip learning
et on avait relié ça à la notion de
fractal en mathématiques qui est
d'ailleurs parfaitement illustré par
cette étonnante expérience de chimie sur
laquelle on reviendra plus tard
aujourd'hui on va aller plus loin dans
notre raisonnement remplaçant les
fractales par une notion qui me semble
encore plus fondamentale à savoir la
profondeur logique de bennett
oui parce que s'il ya un truc
spectaculaire dans notre univers un truc
vraiment officines qui rend notre
univers merveilleux un truc plus
incroyable encore que la relativité
générale que la mécanique quantique et
que les vidéos de chats sur youtube à la
fois pour l'informaticien que je suis en
tout cas c'est bien l'incroyable
profondeur logique de bennett de
l'univers tel qu'il est aujourd'hui
ainsi que son énorme sophistication
solomonoff mais on va s'arrêter à sur la
notion de profondeur logique pour
aujourd'hui
oui parce qu'en plus d'être une source
d'émerveillement sans fin cette
profondeur logique stupéfiante pourra
bien être également la raison principale
de la déraisonnable efficacité du dip
leur nid en tout cas c'est ce que rachid
diguer raul et moi avons suggéré dans
cet article de recherche plein de
conjectures qui me semble vrai quoi
qu'elles soient très largement
indémontrable bref aujourd'hui on parle
de l'une des notions les plus
fascinantes des algorithmique
et pour commencer on va parler un peu de
cosmologie en particulier de l'histoire
et que futur de l'univers ce qui
remarquable avec le début et la fin de
notre univers
c'est que ces deux états sont
remarquablement pas remarquable
ils sont même incroyablement ennuyeux
dans les deux cas il s'agit d'un univers
où rien d'intéressant de ce produit car
la seule description macroscopique
pertinence de ces univers aussi c'est à
dire qu'il s'agit d'un mélange homogène
de matière et d'énergie dans ces deux
états il n'ya pas d'être vivant pas
d'être vivant pas de cerveau pas de
cerveau pas de découvertes mathématiques
et pas de découvertes mathématiques pas
de découvertes mathématiques et c'est
quand même triste mais étrangement entre
ces deux extrêmes ennuyeux à mourir
l'univers est passé par une phase
transitoire absolument fascinante avec
des filaments cosmique des galaxies
autour de trous noirs supermassifs des
systèmes solaires quasi stable et même
des planètes qui abrite des écosystèmes
où interagissent constamment des êtres
vivants si divers et variés et sur
certaines planètes au moins une ya même
des individus pensant à l'aide de
cerveau d'une complexité formidable
capable d'appliquer inconsciemment des
approximations de la formule de pays et
même de réfléchir consciemment aux
conséquences de la forme et le buzz
nous vivons dans une période fantastique
de notre univers une période d'une
complexité astronomique banques rendent
est astronomique rare une période d'une
sophistication spectaculaire fnr est
passagère
[Musique]
ok je pense qu'un tweet ivement on est
tous d'accord pour dire que notre
univers actuel est particulièrement
complexe
mais est ce qu'on pourrait dire cela de
façon rigoureuse il y aurait-il une
quantification possible de la complexité
intuitive de l'univers actuel
quand il s'agit de mesurer l'ordre et le
désordre de systèmes physiques
les physiciens ont tendance à rapidement
évoqué la notion d'entropie l'entropie
d'un système dit on souvent mesures sont
des ordres
sauf qu'en fait ce n'est pas tout à fait
le cas techniquement ce que l'entropie
mesure vraiment c'est l'incertitude
microscopiques qui persistent sachant
une description macroscopique et d'un
système physique et ça ne correspond pas
vraiment à ce que longtemps usuellement
par la notion de complexité d'un système
physique
en effet vous avez sans doute déjà
entendu parler de la seconde loi de la
thermodynamique qui dit que l'entropie
de tout système fermé ne peut
qu'augmenter et ça on peut l'appliquer à
l'univers entier ce qui implique alors
que l'univers a commencé à faible
entropie et va atteindre un état de très
grandes entre opi voilà qui ne colle pas
du tout avec l'intuition selon laquelle
la complexité de l'univers a émergé et
va disparaître le physicien sean carole
et l'informaticien scott aronson ont
décidé de collaborer ensemble pour
formaliser et révéler les mystères de la
notion intuitive de complexité de
l'univers actuel et dans un merveilleux
article initialement et rené et corrigé
par lauren ouellette qui a du coup
rejoint la bande
aronsson carole et donc où elle est on
proposait 4 formalisation de la notion
de complexité intuitive la complexité du
cône de lumière la sophistication de
kolmogorov la complexité apparente et
donc la profondeur logique de bennett
bon alors la complexité du cône de
lumière est un peu intrigué physicien
donc je vais laisser ça de côté pour
aujourd'hui à la sophistication de
kolmogorov c'est vraiment un truc génial
mais dans mon livre je montre qu'il
s'agit d'un cas particulier d'un truc
qui me semble plus fondamental est que
j'ai appelé la sophistication de
solomonoff et malheureusement ou pas il
me faudrait au moins un épisode dédié
pour expliquer tout ça la complexité
apparente elle c'est un peu une
approximation facile à calculer de la
sophistication de kolmogorov que aronson
carole et ouellette ont utilisé pour
leur simulation
enfin et surtout la profondeur logique
de bennett c'est la notion qui va nous
intéresser aujourd'hui
dernière chose avant de vous en parler
les trois auteurs ont montré que les
quatre notion est
est intimement liées les unes aux autres
et donc on peut imaginer qu'il suffit à
peu près d'être complexe selon l'un des
quatre critères pour être complexe selon
tous les critères
même si ce n'est pas techniquement
toujours le cas alors cette profondeur
logique de beineix c'est quoi et bien la
profondeur logique de bennett c'est une
sorte de mesure de la subtilité
algorithmique d'un état physique
détaillons pour commencer comme souvent
en informatique ou commence par tout
ramener à des données c'est-à-dire une
suite de 0 et de 1 donc typiquement si
on été exhaustif on pourrait décrire les
positions et les vitesses de toutes les
particules de l'univers à l'aide d'une
suite de 0 et de 1 ou si on est un peu
plus paresseux on peut prendre toutes
sortes de photos de son et de vidéos de
nous fait divers et les a enregistrées
au format jpeg mp3 ou mp4
bref on obtient alors une longue suite
de 0 et de 1 la profondeur logique de
bennett sera alors une mesure de la
subtilité algorithmique de cette suite
de 0 et de 1
et pour mesurer cette subtilité
algorithmique on va d'abord chercher des
descriptions plus succincte de la suite
de 0 et de 1
typiquement si on a une suite de deux
millions 2 0 on pourra efficacement la
résumer en disant qu'il s'agit d'une
suite de deux millions 2 0 la
description de la suite est ici beaucoup
plus courte que la suite elle même ok
juste pour vérifier que vous avez bien
compris si j'ai maintenant un million 2
0 suivi de un million de 1 page envie de
dire même combat que se passe-t-il
maintenant si je prends une suite
aléatoire 2 0 et 2 hors bien cette fois
je vais être bien embêté en effet les
suit et aléatoires ont justement la
propriété de n'avoir aucune description
succincte
en fait la seule façon de décrire une
suite aléatoire c'est de la décrire
chiffres par chiffres on voit d'ailleurs
avec cet exemple d'où vient la notion
d'entropie l'entropie de la suite
aléatoire et très grande car elle ne
dispose pas de description macroscopique
précise but de long une suite aléatoire
de zéro et de rats ne peut pas en dire
grand chose à part le fait qu'il
s'agisse d'une suite 2 0 et de rats il
subsistera alors une énorme incertitude
microscopique sur les valeurs précises
des éléments de la suite d'où la très
grande entropie des suites aléatoire ok
prenons un quatrième et dernier exemple
qui va être les 2 millions premiers
chiffres du nombre de g
ce nombre gargantuesque dont on a parlé
dans le premier épisode de la série sur
l'infini
cette fois la suite obtenu sera facile à
décrire exactement
ok on a donc vu que quatre exemples
alors intuitivement selon vous lesquels
de ces exemples sont complexes
lesquels ont des subtilités
algorithmique et bien l'idée de cars
planète c'est de considérer que la
subtilité algorithmique d'une suite de 0
et de 1 et le temps de calcul de
l'algorithme qui génère cette suite de 0
et de 1 le temps de calcul de cet
algorithme est ce qu'on appelle la
profondeur logique de bennett
ça correspond donc au nombre d'étapes de
raisonnement logique nécessaire pour
passer d'une description complète de la
suite aux calculs complet des éléments
de la suite dans le cas du premier
exemple cette profondeur est très faible
il suffit d'écrire deux millions 2 0 à
la suite dans le second exemple elle est
évidemment encore très faible de façon
plus intrigante dans le troisième
exemple la profondeur logique de bennett
est encore très faible
en effet puisque la description exacte
d'une suite aléatoire et la suite
aléatoire elle même il suffit de copier
coller cette description de la suite
pour déterminer les chiffres de la suite
mais le quatrième exemple est plus
étrange encore en effet bien que la
description de la suite et très
succincte le temps de calcul nécessaire
pour calculer cette suite est
gargantuesque
il semble en effet qu'il faille faire
une grosse partie du calcul du nombre de
grammes pour arriver à calculer cette
suite
or ce calcul prendra un temps qui sera
probablement de l'ordre de grandeur du
nombre de grammes lui même et même si on
arrivait à diviser ce temps de calcul
par un googleplex vu qu'un googleplex et
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup plus
petit que le nombre de grammes
c'est comme s'ils restaient encore en
gros un nombre de grammes de calculs à
effectuer ainsi notre quatrième exemple
à une grande profondeur logique de
bennett car il y a beaucoup de calculs
algorithmique nécessaire pour passer de
la meilleure description de la suite aux
valeurs des éléments de la suite ok mais
qu'est ce que tout ça a à voir avec
notre univers est bien la thèse que
défendent aronson carole et ouellette
c'est que l'univers a commencé avec une
très faible profondeur logique de
bennett et qu'il finira avec une très
faible profondeur logique de bennett
mais entre les deux aujourd'hui il
possède la propriété extrêmement rare et
précieuse d'avoir une énorme profondeur
le
de bennett en effet tellement de
phénomènes de notre côté on peut être
compris à condition de requérir à des
normes puissance de calcul en fait
l'importance même des technologies de
l'information dans nos sociétés modernes
bien de cette importance du calcul qui
semble venir elle même de l'énorme
profondeur logique de bennett de notre
univers actuel
aronsson carole et ouellette vous même
plus loin en suggérant qu'il s'agit là
d'une propriété récurrente dans
l'évolution de nombreux systèmes dont
l'entropie et initialement faibles et
pour s'en convaincre dans leur article
il propose d'étudier le mélange de lait
temps du café
mais on peut revenir à l'expérience de
chimie a réalisé par bruzy coeur à la
geek touch il y a quelques mois pour
profiter de ces belles images
alors il s'agit d'une réaction
chronomètre alliod et bien sûr le truc
qui fascine c'est que la réaction n'a
pas lieu instantanément
même si elle a tout de même mieux
rapidement bon je passe les détails
chimiques sous silence mais vraiment à
les suivre pour les écarts sur twitter
si c'est vous fascine
moi ce qui m'intéresse particulièrement
dans cette vidéo c'est le moment là vous
voyez alors qu'initialement le mélange
son bep très simple à décrire un liquide
homogène transparent et qu'après il est
tout aussi simple à décrire liquide
homogène bleu foncé il y à une phase
intermédiaire plein de subtilités
algorithmique avec notamment plaints de
figure fractale
et bien ce que les simulations
d'harrison carole et ouellette suggère
c'est que ces figure fractale
intermédiaires dont une grande
complexité apparente ce qui suggère
qu'elles ont aussi une grande profondeur
logique de bennett mollahs qui boucle la
boucle et suggère que la particularité
fondamentale de l'état physique de notre
univers actuel
le truc qui le rend absolument
fantastique est plein de merveilles
c'est cette fameuse profondeur logique
de bennett et ça ça expliquerait la
déraisonnable efficacité du diplôme ning
oui parce que du coup ça suggère clé
bonne description de notre environnement
sont des descriptions plein de
subtilités algorithmique qui requiert un
grand nombre d'étapes de calcul pour
être transformés en prédictions or seule
la profondeur d'un réseau de neurones
permet cette succession d'étapes de
calcul que requiert tout bon modèle de
notre univers notre univers semble donc
nécessité du diplôme ning pour être
compris et ça c'est une réflexion qui
fait réfléchir tant les semble profonde
la lymphe en avait déjà essayé
d'expliquer la déraisonnable efficacité
du diplo ning en parlant notamment des
fractales et antoine ged demande si le
cerveau humain est plutôt large ou
profonds et bien il a l'air déjà d'être
pas mal profond puisque c'est
précisément la profondeur du réseau de
nos
humain qui a inspiré les chercheurs en
intelligence artificielle et qui les a
amenés à considérer des réseaux de
neurones artificiels profond alors il ya
même encore un truc un peu plus
intéressant à noter qui est fait que la
profondeur si on mesure ça en nombre
d'étapes de calcul et vient
potentiellement avec des réseaux
récurrents il est infini puisque le
calcul peut boucler à l'infini bon c'est
de bouc à l'infini comme on a déjà parlé
dans un épisode précédent ça pose
beaucoup de problèmes au niveau de
l'apprentissage mais il a forte apparaît
que tout bon algorithme doivent avoir ce
genre de boucles de rétroaction qui
correspond si vous faites le choix du
piton à une boucle wilde ou à une boucle
fort ce genre de boucler vraiment en
fait on y présente dans les logiciels
que l'on utilise aujourd'hui et ce qui
est intéressant c'est qu'il est possible
que ce genre de boucles qui peut être
également programmées par des
algorithmes dit récursif ce genre de
recursion en particulier sans quelque
chose d'absolument fondamentales y
compris pour le cerveau humain et c'est
quelque chose dont stanislas dehaene
parlement dans un de ses cours au
collège de france sur le cerveau
barisien on parle notamment de travaux
de georges tenenbaum un des experts en
neurosciences notamment tout ce qui nous
rend science proche du machine learning
est autrement des idées béziers
notamment dans son article avec d'autres
co auteur thénot mam suggère que
apprendre à compter c'est apprendre un
algorithme récursif préfet quand on a un
compte à terme ans on compte sur les
doigts ou rompre avec les doigts voire 1
2 3 4 comme ça en fait ce qu'on a appris
à faire c'est un faire en sorte que
chaque mouvement du doigt soit associée
à nos tapis louisiens qui consiste à
prononcer le prochain mot de la suite
des nombres et à passer le doigt vers
les choses suivantes que l'on compte et
cet algorithme qu'on apprend est un
algorithme récursif puisqu'il consiste à
dire prononce le nom du numéro auquel tu
es lorsque tu prends un objet est
ensuite passez au suivant
il répète l'opération et cet aspect est
très récursif et le fait que le cerveau
maîtrise joueurs de pression montre qui
en fait il est capable d'algorithmes
très très très long potentiellement très
très long après le cerveau finit par
fatiguer et ses boucles estiment qu'ils
font que son outil gloubi il se force à
oublier à certains moments raisonnement
qu'il est en train de faire mais tout
cela suggère que le cerveau et au moins
capable de faire pas mal d'opérations de
calcul à la suite mais vu notre faible
attention à notre faible capacité de
concentration notamment via forte
appareil que ce nombre d'opérations
successives dont le cerveau humain est
capable est en fait assez limité en fait
c'est très dur de suivre tout une preuve
mathématique point par point de a à z de
typiquement a tendance à s'intéresser un
bout validé en bout puis regard d'un
autre nouvelle terre notre bout ça ça
vient sans doute du fait que le cerveau
humain est limitée dans sa capacité à
enchaîner les étapes de calcul bruno
moreau lui fait la remarque que ces
notions de frags cas d espèce de très
grandes dimensions sont des choses qu'il
a beaucoup de mal à visualiser bienvenue
au club
à ces objets très très très difficile à
visualiser possible de visualiser
intuitivement et du coup il faut se
restreindre à des opérations
mathématiques et à des descriptions
mathématiques de ces différents objets
fractals pétrole et que c'est que
justement même ses descriptions
mathématiques sont extrêmement compliqué
et ça ça revient à dire qu'en fait la
complexité de ce groupe dont on avait
déjà parlé dans un épisode précédent
notamment de ce qu'est un chat ou de ce
qu'est différents objets et l'ensemble
des chats typiquement ce sont des objets
qui sont impossible à décrire en peu de
mots et tout ça avec elle c'est très
très difficile à visualiser tout ça mais
juste pour expliquer un petit peu plus
le rôle du diplôme ning et son apport
avec les spectacles l'idée que j'ai
essayé de défendre dans la vidéo
précédente
c'est que le sous-ensemble des chats
vraiment un sous-ensemble des images qui
est sans doute un nouveau un ensemble
assez ouverte au sens où il va ti visant
à contenir des petites boules vertes ce
qu'ils voient ce moment à dire qu'en
fait le concept de chats et robuste à
des attaques par pixel ou par
combinaison de
de pixels du coup c'est vraiment un
sous-ensemble a priori et avec une
certaine frontières et l'idée que
j'essaie de défendre dans la vidéo
précédente c'est que cette frontière est
sans doute une structure très fractales
qui bouge beaucoup dans tous les sens et
l'objectif du réseau de neurones c'est
un peut projeter cette frontière pour la
rendre aussi pour la des fractales ise
on rôde d'avoir une fonction qui sera
donc le réseau de neurones qui
transforme cette frontière fractales
bizarroïde en quelque chose il est
allemand qui ressemblerait à une droite
donc vraiment complètement là des
fractales is et l'on vit d'ailleurs
puisque la droite c'est vraiment le truc
le moins fréquemment on envie de dire
fait même mieux que ça plutôt qu'une
droite pourrait que ce soit plus un
espèce d'hyper plan dans un certain
espace vectoriel de sémantique
l'idée c'est que cette hyper plan en
fonction de là on est du côté de cette
hyper plan du côté chats ou pacha donc
cette hyper plan par rapport au réseau
de zones ça correspondrait au synap 130r
est fonction de l'activation du dernier
haut rhône qui est le neurone
responsable de la détection de chat ou
de pacha dans le réseau de neurones
bref tout ça pour suggérer le fait que
un réseau de neurones doit être profond
pour réussir à sa manière des fractales
is et les frontières fractales qui nous
sont intéressants c'est une utilisée en
pratique pour par exemple pas de parler
des chats à supposer bien sûr que c'est
ensemble des chats à une frontière
fractale j'espère que vous avez aimé cet
épisode qui clôt toute la partie sur les
réseaux de neurones on en a bientôt fini
avec cette série sur intelligence
artificielle ne reste plus que trois
épisodes et les trois derniers épisodes
de parleront pas mal de l'article que
j'ai écrit sur le problème du bayou
loading en particulier la prochaine fois
vous faire un titre très pratique
puisque je vous présenterai ma solution
contre le changement climatique
si vous avez aimé cet épisode sans sel
l'ikea le commentaire de partage et
pensez à vous abonner pour une planque
et futurs épisodes
merci aux ti peu à peu leurs dons
j'espère que vous serez là la prochaine
fois peut-être que la notion complexité
structurelle de complexité organisé ça
serait lié à la quantité de calcul
présente dans un objet plus un objet va
être restructurée plus il va contenir
une sorte de traces qu'il est le
résultat d'un calcul
charles bennett a proposé une définition
qui semble toucher le but est donc ils
provoquent la chance il entier pas du
tout évidente c'est pas du tout évident
c'est pour ça qu'on a mis tant de temps
la définition était proposée qu'en 1977
donc qu'on appelle la profondeur logique
de bennett et qui est une tentative pour
exprimer cette notion de mesures de
complexité organisée c'est le temps de
calcul du programme minimum minimale à
ses toiles du produit